Marquez Bradley is one of the biggest
and most respected Tech YouTubers in the
world I asked him how he scaled his
channel to 16 million subscribers and
here's what he said so their active
personality is like as you start off as
a Creator you're a solo Creator there
are all these different things that you
do that you really want to be good at
but you you have a main focus so for me
it was like I want to review Tech I want
to talk about tech but I also have to be
a professional cameraman and I have to
be a professional video editor and
lighter and I have to be a professional
inbox manager and and finance an
accounting and taxes and I also have to
do all this other behind the scenes
stuff and audio and and the list goes on
and so you feel like an octopus you've
got eight armed they're all doing
different things in order to stay on
track at this point the team we've built
is all of the arms that I've cut off
so they're all much better than I am at
holding a camera they're much better
than I am at set design they're much
better than I am at sound design at
still Graphics so the thumbnails are all
better the the sound is all better
everything is better about everything we
make because of the team and that is the
purpose of the